So what do I mean by the cross-correlation method?
In signal processing, cross-correlation is a measure of similarity of two
different waveforms as a function of the time-lag applied to one of them.
What that basically means is that I have two different signals, two different
waveforms, and I want to combine them to figure out what are the best ways that
I can correlate the two different signals together, and allow me to kind of
do things, of measuring the similarity between those signals.
We will look at that for a variety of reasons when we get into feature
detection and stuff in the later lectures, but this is an important part of
what we want to actually look at a little bit more carefully now.
And then actually we'll use that to develop other concepts.
Another way of looking at the cross-correlation is also considering it
as a sliding dot product, or an inner-product of two different signals.
And you witness this when we actually look at a smaller kernel and
we slid it over a bigger image and actually computed at the center, or
a representative point, the output which was the combination, or
an inert dot product of those two signals.
And that's an important part on how the process unfolded as we looked at
how we did the processing or filtering in the last lecture.
Mathematical notation of cross-correlation is shown here.
Again, we are using the two summations and
looping over the whole image here with non-uniform attribute weights.
Mathematically, we will denote this by symbol here,
where basically the kernel h is being cross-correlated with the out,
input signal, F, to generate an output G.
So what do we mean when we say now, we are filtering an image?
What we mean by filtering an image here is,
what we are doing is replacing each pixel in the output with
a linear combination of its neighbors with a kernel matrix.
And for each one of them, there is a kernel or a mask signal, h here.
And basically that is a prescription, a function
of weights which is applied as a linear combination to generate an output G.
And we saw this as I rubbed over,
again h over the input image F to generate the output G, earlier.